what could possibly make a game about
mechs and jumping any better how about
grapple hooks I'm Kate and this is your
gamespot news update titanfall 2 will
introduce new pilot abilities a
grappling hook and have bigger maps
according to a post on the game
subreddit the information which has
since been deleted was leaked by the
subreddits moderator I love Google glass
who cites someone in the know as their
source according to the leak titanfall 2
will release in October this falls in
line with previous indications from
publisher EA which confirmed in an
earnings report that the game is
scheduled for a fiscal q3 release this
period spans October 2016 through to the
end of December 2016 the post included
this artwork which notably doesn't
include the grappling hook which can
reportedly be used for getting into
Titans from a distance pulling enemies
out of the air and extending free
running in a separate League a facebook
fan page for mountain dews game fuel
states that there will be a promotional
tie in with titanfall 2 for the beverage
this the reddit post claims is also
legitimate do you think the grappling
hook is likely to be the main new
mechanic or are you hoping for something
a bit more exciting or are you just more
interested in the mountain dew tie and
let me know in the comments or come find
me on Twitter I'm at how not to draw
thanks for watching and for all your
gaming and entertainment news keep it
gamespot